j'aimerais tout d'abord vous faire
réaliser une petite acrobatie digital
vous êtes prêts je vous propose de lever
l'une de vos mains allez-y ensuite je
vous propose de rapprocher tout
doucement votre index de votre pouce en
conscience
quand on m'a demandé de participer à ce
tedx j'ai vraiment eu envie de refuser
puis après les orateurs les
organisateurs pardon ont eu la bonne
idée de me dire que la thématique était
ensemble
alors là j'ai pensé à toutes ces
personnes que j'accompagne au quotidien
à toutes ces personnes à qui on n'aurait
peut-être pas proposer ce tedx les
personnes que j'accompagne on soit une
déficience intellectuelle soit un
handicap psychique ou mentale alors je
me suis dit ces personnes là est ce
qu'elles auraient leur place ici et j'en
suis pas sûr parce que par exemple une
partie des personnes que j'accompagne
sont des personnes avec un trouble du
spectre de l'autisme
ce trouble est un trouble
neurodéveloppemental qui amène les
personnes qu'ils en sont porteurs à des
trajectoires de vie particulières
si vous les rencontrez vous verrez elles
ont une façon très atypique d'entrer en
contact avec vous elles ont des intérêts
particuliers d intérêt inhabituel ou des
intérêts qui paraissent spéciaux en
fonction de l'âge des personnes
ils ont des difficultés aussi à gérer
les stimulations sensorielles et une
autre de leurs particularités et des
difficultés avec le langage
les paires certaines personnes que
j'accompagne quotidien nos mêmes n'ont
même aucun langage oral dans une société
où l'on s'exprime avec des mots non pour
si impossible pour elle donc d'être ici
ce soir et de vous parler
alors j'ai dit oui je serai là et
j'essayerai de parler non pas pour elle
mais de partager ce que j'ai vécu avec
elle alors je suis consciente que je ne
peux pas exprimer véritablement ce
qu'elles ressentent mais je vais vous
fait
pars pars d'une petite partie de mon
quotidien alors avant de vous inviter
dans ce quotidien dans le mien de
quotidiens et dans le leur je vous
propose de faire un petit détour dans
l'histoire d'hélène nicolas hélène
nicolas est une jeune femme aujourd'hui
de 33 ans qui a été diagnostiqué dans
son enfance avec un trouble du spectre
de l'autisme est une déficience sévère
hélène nicolas a intégré une institution
à l'âge de 8 ans après quelques années
dans cette institution et les instituts
l institution c'est déclare s'est trouvé
en fait
impuissante à l'accompagner et quand
elle a eu 14 ans sa maman véronique a
décidé de la reprendre à la maison elle
a continué son parcours au quotidien
avec sa maman ait atteint l'âge de 15
ans elle a commencé à peindre elle
n'arrivait pas l affaire ce petit geste
que vous avez fait avec semble-t-il
passablement de faciliter tout à l'heure
impossible pour elle d' approcher son
pouce de l'index par contre l arrivée à
peindre elle a fait des peintures
abstraites
elle a pu faire des expositions et elle
a pu commencer à entrer en contact de
cette façon là avec le monde auparavant
c'était très difficile
à l'âge de 20 ans elle a réussi à faire
ce petit geste et sa maman à ce
moment-là eu l'intuition qu'hélène était
capable de comprendre le langage écrit
elle arrivait à lire alors elle lui a
fabriqué une boîte en bois avec des
lettres et la ln a commencé à prendre
ces lettres et avec difficulté certes
mais tout de même
elle a réussi a commencé à écrire et là
elle a livré selon ses mots tout ce qui
était auparavant enfermé en elle-même et
l'a publié son premier recueil de poèmes
en 2006 et elle s'est auto nommé babou
iec
baboo iec très déclaré sans paroles
alors malgré cette trajectoire de vie
particulières malgré cet outil de
communication gehlen et sa maman ont pu
fabriquer ensemble ont pu créer ensemble
hélène ne pourrait pas être ici ce soir
dans ce têt dicks
parce qu'elles n'arrivent pas à répondre
finalement aux normes de ce tel x à
savoir pouvoir s'exprimer oralement et
exprimer un message en 18 minutes
donc c'est moi qui suis là et qui
essayent vous l'avez vu avec un peu de
difficulté à répondre aux normes de cet
édit qs vous propose maintenant d'entrer
dans mon quotidien avec lara qui avait
là 17 ans 17 ans et demi clara n'a pas
pu intégrer l'école ordinaire elle a
toujours été dans une école spécialisée
et là elle arrive l'âge de 18 ans comme
tous les jeunes c'est un peu excitant
d'avoir 18 ans pour elle aussi
et son rêve c'est d'intégrer une
institution qui prépare les jeunes
adultes à la vie professionnelle pouvoir
intégrer ce centre lui aux rives ou
louer lui ouvrirait de belles
perspectives
elles pourraient trouver une profession
qui lui plairait peut-être mais pour
entrer dans cette institution il ya une
condition c'est savoir faire en toute
autonomie le trajet de son domicile à
l'institution et clara n'y arrive pas
actuellement dans les dix dans ses
déplacements elle a besoin de sa maman
et voilà son premier rêve un petit peu
s'écroule
clara ne pourra pas intégrer cette
institution là il ya parfois des choses
qui nous paraissent évidentes qui sont
beaucoup moins évidentes pour des
personnes qui ont une trajectoire de vie
différente
18 ans c'est un passage compliqué pour
tous les jeunes ou plutôt un passage
excitant comme je disais tout à l'heure
mon fils par exemple quand il a eu 18
ans
c'était super il disait je vais pouvoir
ok je dois remplir ma déclaration
d'impôts mais d'un autre côté je peux
aussi remplir mes excuses pour l'école
tout seul et puis moi ça marche un peu
moins drôle parce qu'il m'a mis sur
liste d'attentes par rapport à
l'utilisation de ma propre voiture
et puis pour monfils 18 ans était
c'était aussi l'occasion d'avoir un rêve
partir à l'étranger faire des études
avoir son propre appartement et se
débrouiller tout seul
mais pour lui c'est assez évident il a
appris à faire la lessive et il m'a
demandé de lui acheter un livre de
cuisine
mais pour bernard 21 ans que je côtoie
tous les jours
bernard a aussi une déficience
intellectuelle
et bernard lui me dit comme mon fils moi
mon rêve anne-claude bientôt je vais
quitter l'institution dans laquelle je
suis et j'aurai mon propre appartement
serait autonome
alors moi chaque fois je lui dis mais
c'est super bernard c'est vraiment un
beau projet je vois que tu as vraiment
envie d'y arriver et bien je pense que
on va s'y mettre ensemble et tu vas y
arriver
et puis c'est pas pourquoi l'autre jour
bernard est revenu vers moi et bernard
m'a dit comme d'habitude anne-claude
bientôt j'aurai mon propre appartement
je veux pouvoir être autonome et là je
lui ai demandé mais bernard ça veut dire
quoi pour toi
être autonome et là bernard m'a regardée
et puis m'a dit il ya des tournées un
petit peu son regard et puis m'a dit
anne claude faut que tu m'aides je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire être
autonome ce qui peut paraître évident à
nos jeunes qui ont une trajectoire
traditionnelle classique ne l'est pas
pour toutes les autres personnes qui ont
des trajectoires différentes pour la mia
elle aussi à l'aube de ses 18 ans une
grande question se pose elle aimerait
aller elle aimerait aussi intégrer le
milieu professionnel
mais elle n'y arrive pas et elle me dit
souvent un autre je suis horrible
horrible
oui si horrible à 18 ans je joue encore
avec mes chevaux en plastique
c'est pas comme ça qu'on doit être à 18
ans c'est pas normal que je fasse ça
comme ça
la mia a aussi un trouble du spectre de
l'autisme et un haut potentiel
elle a suivi elle colle arrêter toute
ordinaire elle a même été souvent
première de classe elle en est fière
mais quand elle est arrivée au bout de
sa scolarité c'est devenu trop difficile
pour elle obligatoire pardon c'est
devenu trop difficile pour elle de
répondre à tout ce que la société exigé
d'elle elle avait beaucoup de peine à
gérer ça sensorialité différentes et
c'est ces contacts sociaux
pour lamia par exemple être ici ce soir
ça serait pas possible
beaucoup trop de manques beaucoup trop
de lumière beaucoup trop de stimulation
dans un lieu avec beaucoup de monde elle
se sent vraiment pas bien pour elle
aussi se laver les mains avec de l'eau
et du savon c'est presque impossible
parce qu'en fait de m elle s'en tire sur
sa peau le contact de l'eau et du savon
provoque des douleurs insupportables
elle m'a dit aussi un jour je peux pas
partir de la maison et faire un
apprentissage sinon je vais mourir
je suis dit mais mourir pourquoi parce
que je peux pas manger une autre cuisine
que celle de ma maman difficile pour
lamia de continuer difficile pour lamia
de comprendre aussi que la société exige
d'elles de quitter ces petits chevaux
pour avancer de quitter son univers de
manga en idées univers extraordinaire
qui pourtant donne beaucoup de sens à sa
vie tout à fait extraordinaire quand on
se trouve face à des personnes qui ont
un handicap mental ou psychique
c'est difficile de savoir ce qui est
possible ou impossible quand on se
trouve face à une personne en chaise
roulante
personne n'aurait l'idée de demander à
cette personne de monter des escaliers
au contraire on va construire une rampe
un ascenseur parce qu'on est conscient
que c'est nécessaire d'apporter un
aménagement de l'environnement pour que
la personne puisse accéder aux mêmes
salles ou même bâtiment que nous mais
quand on se trouve face à des personnes
qui ont un handicap psychique ou mental
c'est beaucoup plus difficile c'est
difficile de savoir ce qui est possible
ce qui est impossible
on a souvent tendance à leur dire mais
fait un effort mais parfois c'est pas
possible
et je voudrais vous raconter là
l'histoire de lisa lisa a aujourd'hui 27
ans elle a aussi un trouble
neurodéveloppemental très proche de
celui de l'autisme alors lisa a commencé
à l'âge de 16 ans un apprentissage
elle était dans un apprentissage
classique en milieu ordinaire mais elle
aussi elle s'est retrouvé confronté à
ses limites c'était difficile pour elle
de répondre aux exigences de son métier
mais aussi aux exigences de son patron
de son entourage il y avait une exigence
qui était particulièrement difficile
pour elle c'était regarder ses
interlocuteurs dans les yeux quand elle
sera quand elle parler à quelqu'un
et encore et toujours que ce soit son
patron son entourage ses collègues lui
disais mais regarde les gens dans les
yeux
lisa n'y arrivait pas parfois son
mal-être été telles qu'elle s'auto
mutiler et puis les a tout de même
réussi son apprentissage
elle n'a pas réussi à regarder les gens
dans les yeux mais elle a quand même
réussi cet apprentissage mais elle n'a
pas pu intégrer
finalement le monde du travail ordinaire
elle a dû trouver un lieu de travail on
a pu aménager son offre cet
environnement pour qu'elle puisse se
sentir à l'aise elle a eu des ailes à
des horaires adaptés elle à une visite
hebdomadaire chez son médecin elle fait
beaucoup de sport et elle se repose
beaucoup mais elle a pu grâce à ces
aménagements petit à petit se crée un
très bel équilibre est aujourd'hui à 27
ans elle est apaisée et elle regarde ses
interlocuteurs dans les yeux ces normes
sociales qui veut qu'on regarde les gens
dans les yeux sont des normes qui sont
fortement ancrées
je pense qu'il ya des parents parmi vous
on a beaucoup qui ont demandé à leurs
enfants mais regarde la personne que tu
salut dans les yeux et bien pour une
personne avec un trouble de l'autisme
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
difficile
ça pourrait être aussi difficile que si
je vous demandais là maintenant de
réciter le nombre pi avec 22 1514
décimales est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous
qui arrive à le faire et bien daniel
tammet qui est lui aussi diagnostiqué
avec un trouble du spectre de l'autisme
le ferais très facilement par contre il
lui serait beaucoup plus difficile de
regarder son interlocuteur dans les yeux
les normes sociales sont très relative
il ya une vingtaine d'années je me suis
retrouvé en inde que j'étais invité à
manger dans une dans une famille de
caste élevé les femmes de la famille
avait cuisiné un repas un très bon repas
c'était assez extraordinaire et à la fin
du repas c'était assez génial tout le
monde s'est mis à rater
et ben oui en inde
si on veut être poli à la fin de repas
il faut voter
il ya une personne autour de la table
qui a pas réussi à voter
devinez
c'était moi j'ai pas réussi j'étais
tellement façonné par la norme
occidental qui dit crottet c'est mal
polique je n'ai pas pu être poli en inde
et dreux t il n'y a rien de plus relatif
et de plus finalement
et ça exclut en fait la norme sociale
alors je terminerai avec alain 13 ans
alain est un passionné d'avions
miniatures
il a lui aussi un trouble du spectre de
l'autisme et alain la grande chance
d'avoir pu intégrer l'école ordinaire et
donc en inclusion et alain m'a dit un
jour quand je suis à l'école je dois
être normal alors je laisse mes avions à
la maison quand je suis à la maison je
peux être moi même je vais dans ma
chambre et je joue avec mes avions
arf dream disait martin luther king qui
rêvait que les hommes noirs et les
hommes blancs soit égaux en droits alors
moi je ne suis pas martin luther king
mais j'ai aussi un rêve je rêve d'un
monde où chacun pourrait être normal en
toutes circonstances sans se soucier
d'être normale
[Applaudissements]